now speaking of which this may be one of
the last segments I do about tulsi
gabbard okay
and it's an interesting one tulsi
gabbard gave a ridiculously laughable
interview to cultural critic and arbiter
of big ideas Dave Rubin
wherein she accepted Dave Reubens
ridiculous right-wing framing of
questions uncritically much the way that
many of the candidates did during the
early 2020 Democratic presidential
primary debates and Tulsi Gabbard has
now also started to attack Elizabeth
Warren in ways that are absolutely
ridiculous
she is also stepping back from medicare
for all so let's look in detail okay on
NPR's WBUR Tulsi Gabbard was asked about
Medicare for all and she was squirrely
once again saying quote yes I support it
I prefer to call it Medicare choice
where we are ensuring quality health
care for all people regardless of how
little they may have in their pocket or
their bank account while maintaining
their freedom of choice if they've got
an employer-sponsored plan or an Union
sponsored plan that they're happy with
they should have the opportunity to do
so who's talking about taking away
whatever plans can survive in the market
if people want them at what they will
cost if a lot of people abandon those
markets this is the Republican framing
and those are the these are the right
wing questions at debates that need to
be called out as such she's asked do you
support Medicare for all he says well I
support choice because I don't want
people having the plans they have taken
away if they like them that that's the
right wing framing around this issue
that the issue is not making private
insurance illegal here's a clip similar
question that was asked I also believe
like every other developed country in
the world that has universal health care
that there is a role for private
insurance to play for those who want it
do you think for those who are embracing
taking away private insurance from
people ultimately is that just
strategically politically a non-starter
i I don't know about the politics of it
I just think about it from the
perspective of
people of the American people that if
all of a sudden you are taking away
their choice that's not that's not a
very American thing in my opinion I
think our responsibility as leaders is
to meet the challenge and address the
problems that people are facing that
they are suffering because of big
insurance in Big Pharma's influence over
our healthcare system for so long how
they are profiting on the backs of sick
people so let's do our job try to bring
down the cost of health care in this
country that's exorbitant make sure
people can get the quality care they
need and if they still choose that
that's not what they want they can go
get the private insurance I ask focusing
on you shouldn't take away people's
choice this is Republican framing the
debate over making private insurance
illegal is not the real serious debate
this is a silly talking point that is
being used by people who want to avoid
simply saying yes Medicare for all is
the way and you know what you don't have
to say that I would much listen I don't
agree with Joe Biden's position on
health care I just I just think he's
wrong I don't agree with it but he's at
least being upfront that he doesn't see
Medicare for all as the path he's
telling us he wants to play around the
fringes he wants to tweak Obama care
public option he's talking about you
he's telling us what it is that he
supports this is the way that people
talk about Medicare for all when they
want to avoid saying yes I'm for
Medicare for all period or no I'm
actually against it they do this exact
language about I don't want to take away
people's choices now what's crazy is
that there are Tulsi sycophants who just
won't stop accusing anyone who points
out what I'm pointing out here of
misrepresenting her or of being a bad
faith person this is the exact thing
that the jordan peterson sycophants say
anytime you critique jordan peterson you
were accused by his followers of
misrepresenting what he said and that is
exactly what is happening with the many
people who heard what Tulsi said and
realized that it's not really making
sense and then really lame and also
somewhat funny she attacked Tulsi did
Elizabeth Warren for being unqualified
to be President
take a look at this so you've been
critical of Senator hare
in the past and even went so far as to
question whether she was prepared to be
commander-in-chief we now see senator
Warren really rising in the polls she's
first in a lot of national polls and
several state polls as well early state
polls do you believe that she's prepared
to be commander in chief I haven't seen
much come from her in the way of what
kind of leadership and decision-making
that she would bring to that most
important responsibility that the
president has as commander-in-chief and
and just as a soldier an American that
that's very concerning for me so you
know for voters I think that's an
important thing to look out for from
everyone who's running for president is
what kind of experience do you have in
this area what kind of depth and
understanding do you bring to these very
nuanced and complex issues with how the
United States is relating with other
countries what kind of leadership we're
providing in the world and having the
kind of foresight and judgment that
we've seen leaders from across both
party lines have lacked for far too long
that have brought us to this position
where you know for for all three of us
we've seen our country at war for the
vast majority of the years that we've
been alive what is he talking about and
of course you know the necessary both
sides have lacked leadership okay but in
very different ways that are not even
remotely equal so here's the deal first
and foremost for Tulsi to attack
Elizabeth Warren and say Elizabeth
Warren is unqualified to be President
you could generally say we need fewer
lawyers and business people and career
politicians in government instead we
need scientists and you know what you
could have that general conversation and
that's a very good conversation to have
but for Tulsi to say Warren's not
qualified to the extent that being an
elected official qualifies you
Tulsi is a member of the House and
Warren's a member of the Senate view
zero that out then it's a debate is
Warren's experience with the cfpb her
knowledge of the law as a law professor
her experience teaching school Tulsi was
in the military and was a local Hawaii
politician you can say neither's qualify
in the way that we want presidents to be
qualified but for Tulsi to say Warren's
not qualified is just a joke when she's
the one also running for president right
but here's the real issue with Tulsi and
with other candidates let's step back a
little bit from Tulsi and make this a
bigger thing cuz tell us he's gonna be
gone soon she's got no shot at this
thing the cults of personality around
some candidates are problematic Tulsi
Gabbard has a huge cult of personality
around her I've been told although I've
never seen that there are entire YouTube
channels dedicated merely to doing Tulsi
apologia dependent offending anything
she says no matter how outrageous I've
been told there are similar channels
around Andrew yang can you imagine a
youtube channel whose very existence is
just devoted to defending one candidate
like they are sort of heroic or almost
deifying them in some way and I remember
back in 2016 there were channels that
popped up like that around Bernie
Sanders and I voted for Bernie Sanders
in the 2016 Democratic primary but a
channel devoted to defending everything
that Bernie Sanders says and most of
those channels have of course evaporated
since 2016 although some are coming back
so the real problem I have with the
Tulsi sick offense and the Bernie or
Buster's the people who defend Trump
unfailingly unflinchingly is that
they've seemed to Ferg have forgotten
that people are just people one of the
things that hopefully we learn as we
grow up is that everybody is just a
person our parents aren't omnipotent or
omniscient right that that's something
you learn as you come of age our
teachers weren't and aren't all-knowing
they're just people and they know about
some stuff whether you're a Democrat or
a Republican the praying at the altar of
certain candidates like they are excuse
the phrase God's gift to humanity is
extremely concerning some politicians
know more or less about different things
some are more or less experienced but
they're all just people and I've met
enough elected officials to tell you
they really are just people they're
flawed people people who may do many
good things and will also mess things up
and these unflinching cults of
personality from the
devotees are disturbing and strange and
they're not the types of movements I
want to have any pardon and when people
say David why aren't you more strongly
saying this is the person that
progressives need to support in the
Democratic primary I don't see any of
these people as a perfect hypothetically
in quotes rather in the sense that a lot
of the sycophants do and I have no
problem saying you know there's a lot of
people here who are pretty good some are
better than others and there's no reason
for me to now come out and and maybe
sort of unwillingly even participate in
the growth of these cults of personality
I've told you Bernie and Warren are the
most progressive in my eyes they're both
flawed and we're and I'm going to
continue following it but these cults of
personality these movements that that
that are based around almost deifying a
candidate are very very concerning to me
and I want to hear from you what you
think about that we're actually going to
have a couple of posts about this on our
Instagram page at david pakman show
follow us there and follow me on
instagram at david pakman I may be
picking what could be the last green
pepper of the season from my my pepper
plant later today hey really quick I
want to tell you about one of our
partners VIN Charo watches giving our
audience 15% off everything they offer
these guys are awesome they craft really
stylish top-quality watches for both men
and women but they sell them at a fair
price unlike a lot of their competitors
VIN chero assembles their watches in
small batches which enables them to
meticulously ensure the quality of every
watch I personally wear of inch arrow
watch I don't like the idea of spending
thousands of dollars on a watch when I
can get a really excellent watch for a
hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
that's what I think is great about VIN
chair oh you get a watch made from
top-notch materials they look like
watches that you'd spend a ton of money
on and they're built like high-end
watches designed mechanically with
longevity in mind but you don't have to
spend an arm and a leg their entire goal
is to make watches of superior quality
available to the average person I just
got a new one called the Kairos I got
the white and
silver version it looks great I've
gotten a ton of compliments they have a
huge variety of style so it was easy to
find one that fits my tastes there are a
bunch of other companies out there
selling watches at similar prices but a
lot of them look very cookie cutter and
just don't offer the same level of
craftsmanship as what you get from binge
arrow you're not going to find a better
made watch at this grade of a price
they've got a watch for any type of look
you're trying to go for formal more
casual the straps and colors are
interchangeable so you can customize
your watch to your own preference and
you can get 15% off everything in their
store when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch and use the code Pakman at
checkout